today on the mount wall show a mass
shooting at a gay club in Colorado means
that we should stop opposing the
mutilation and sexualization of children
this is the leftist claim anyway how
does it make any sense at all it doesn't
but we'll talk about it also the
president of FIFA attempts to defend his
woke credentials even though he decided
to hold the World Cup in Qatar Trump is
invited back to Twitter but will he
accept the invitation Biden turns 80
years old in the White House and a
four-star college football recruit has
his scholarship withdrawn because he
sang along to a rap song how does that
make any sense at all well it doesn't
either we'll talk about all that and
more today on the Matt Walsh show
[Applause]
[Music]
okay
are you struggling to reach your fitness
goals as it turns out having world-class
instructors plus a community of hundreds
of thousands of people who are working
towards the same goal really does help
the guys at Echelon Fitness have it all
worked out Echelon Fitness is the
affordable way to get workout equipment
a workout community and an instructor's
motivation right in the comfort and
privacy of your own home Echelon Fitness
is connected app provides thousands of
Live And on-demand classes with great
music to keep you moving you can work
out anytime day or night their full
range of affordable workout equipment
includes stationary bikes smart Growers
Sleek Fitness screens and an auto
folding treadmill these are all
connected to the echelon fitness app for
The Full Experience Around the Clock
classes including full body workout
programs will keep you coming back one
membership covers a family of five so
for a limited time my audience can get a
free bike or a rowing machine with a
24-month membership to get your free
bike or rower text Matt to 818181 that's
Matt to 818181 to claim your free bike
or rowing machine text Matt to 818 to
181 message and data rates may apply see
terms for details
the left loves mass shootings this is an
inescapable conclusion I mean not every
person on the left side of the political
Spectrum feels that way certainly but
institutionally the media the pundit
class government officials activists the
leftists who are setting and enacting
the agenda they all love mass shootings
I mean that's why they don't hesitate to
exploit them an exploitation starts
immediately there's no period of
mourning no space given for grief there
certainly isn't a moment taken to let
the dust settle and figure out what
actually happened
that's because it doesn't matter what
actually happened all that matters is
what they can say about what happened
what they can you know do with it how
they can use it
of course such a cynical even
bloodthirsty attitude is no surprise
coming from the same people who support
cheer on facilitate fund the Mass
Slaughter of unborn children these are
not people who value human life or feel
it all squeamish about standing atop the
bodies of the Dead to advance their
political and personal ambitions and so
we cannot be shocked at all by what
we've seen in response to the mass
shooting at a gay club called Club Q and
Colorado Springs over the weekend in
total five people were killed 25 more
were wounded several critically so when
a shooter now identified as 22 year old
Anderson Lee Aldrich opened fire
now at this point there's still no
information about aldrich's motive we
haven't been given any specific details
about why he did what he did but
whatever he says to investigators he was
taken alive we already know the
fundamental reason for the attack
Aldrich is a violent unstable sociopath
that's the reason
I mean how was he able to carry out this
assault well we know that too he was
able to do it because the court system
the D.A and the FBI allowed it
according to reports in many outlets
including Fox News outrage was arrested
just last year for making bomb threats
and refusing to surrender to police when
they came his mother had called polices
back in June of 2021 reporting that her
son had made a bomb threat and was
threatening to was had made a bomb or
said that he had made a homemade bomb
and was threatening to detonate it when
police arrived they found alridge hiding
in a house nearby where he refused to
surrender when they finally managed to
detain him he was charged with
two counts of felony menacing and three
counts of first-degree kidnapping
and then guess what happened
the D.A decided not to pursue charges
why well it's hard to say in fact we
can't say because the case has been
sealed all the records are sealed all we
know is that
um this is yet another case of a violent
mentally ill criminal the fact that he
threatened to blow up his own mother
with a homemade bomb is I think enough
confirmation then he's crazy who was
known to law enforcement known to the
courts and yet for whatever reason was
not sitting in a cage like he ought to
have been
this is the same pattern that appears
and then reappears and appears again
with nearly every violent criminal that
makes it into the national headlines
and with a huge portion of the violent
criminals that don't make it into the
national headlines
Untold thousands of lives could be saved
if the people charged with enforcing our
laws simply enforced them we didn't
there's no there's no new law that we
need in Colorado Springs that would have
prevented the massacre we already have
laws against bomb threats kidnapping
we simply needed it to be enforced with
the punishment that is already
prescribed for it and that would have
been enough yet it wasn't done
this could be the conversation it's an
important conversation and it's not a
holy political conversation the D.A in
Colorado Springs as far as I know is a
republican now yeah it's often woke
Democrat DA's who don't enforce their
own laws but it's not only them and this
is not a problem that concerns only
District Attorneys we have we have a
crisis across the board at every level
of the most basic laws not being
enforced consistently or not being
enforced at all
it's a problem that we should address
and we need to and we could
but the people guiding the public
conversation have no interest in having
that conversation
that's not the conversation they want to
have
because that conversation does not allow
them to demonize their most hated
ideological opponents
in fact on the left if they had the
conversation about not enforcing laws
rather than demonizing people on the
right they'd be agreeing with us
they'd be saying oh you know you were
right about this all along and they
don't want to do that
and so instead the left has decided to
blame conservatives for causing this
last mass shooting through our through
our alleged anti-lgbt rhetoric
the Attorney General of Colorado Phil
Weiser who should be answering questions
about why the laws against kidnapping
aren't being enforced in his State
apparently instead was on CNN this
morning casting the blame as far from
himself as he possibly could listen
thank you so much attorney general for
joining us the major question this
morning has been about motive here is
the suspect speaking to investigators
yet and what have you learned about a
potential motive if anything so the
investigations ongoing and I think it's
fair to say based on the facts it's very
hard to conceive those situations where
the motive wasn't generated by hate this
was a well-known nightclub that
individuals regardless of their sex
orientation or gender identity the lgbtq
community knew was a safe place was a
place where people could be their
authentic cells and someone came and
essentially took all that away because
we know there's so much of this hate out
there particularly towards individuals
who are lgbtq and this is obviously
something that is painful it was on
transgender Remembrance Day when it
happened so this is a call to all of us
to look at that hate and ask what do we
do about it
it's very hard to conceive of a
situation where this incident doesn't
enforce my preferred political narrative
that's what he's saying
he says there's a lot of hate towards
LGBT people
but what is he talking about I mean what
hate
we'll try to figure that out in a moment
but first here's Don Lemon inviting
wiser to continue with this line of
propaganda and he does
everyone we've spoken to there members
of the lgbtq community they have said
that they believe that there's you know
where else could this point to again we
don't know the motive here but can you
talk to us about and you said it was a
safe haven right for members of the
lgbtq community the importance of
elected officials our leaders on social
media the importance of words
and using LGBT members of the lgbtq plus
Community as sort of political Pawns in
politics
can you can you speak to that please
absolutely
we are living at a time of rising hate
and rising demonization and all of us
the leader leadership positions have to
recognize that our words matter
we can and we must have a more inclusive
we the people that's a phrase that
Justice Ginsburg used
the legitimate or legitimization I
should say of hating towards lgbtq plus
individuals has to stop
Don Lemon worries that LGBT people are
being used as pawns and so he proceeds
to use them as pawns I guess you know
answering his own question the Attorney
General meanwhile says that we're living
in a time of rising hate and
demonization and he's right
a good example of this demonization is
the fact that the Attorney General
Colorado is blaming social conservatives
for a mass shooting carried out by a
known violent criminal in his state
but this is the line that every
prominent person on the left has taken
and lots of people that are not as
prominent as well Joe Biden blamed hate
against LGBT people of course glad
issued a statement blaming not just
hateful rhetoric but also legislation
their statement says quote you can draw
a straight line from the false and vile
rhetoric about lgbtq people spread by
extremists and Amplified across social
media to the nearly 300 anti-lgbtq bills
introduced this year to the dozens of
attacks on our community like this one
that this mass shooting took place on
the eve of of transgender Dave
remembrance when we honor the memory of
the trans people killed the prior year
deepens the trauma and tragedy for all
in the lgbtq community the media must
stop spreading misinformation and
Elevate the truth that LGBT people exist
belong and want to live in peace and
safety
so this became immediately the standard
talking point and the left named
specific villains also people who are
most responsible for the shooting
people like well
me for instance I am currently trending
on Twitter because there are so many
tweets like this one from a guy named
Joshua Hill he says quote
this club had a drag show every Saturday
it's impossible to escape the horrifying
conclusion that the escalating rhetoric
against drag queens promoted by people
like Shia right checks Tick Tock Matt
Walsh and others created the environment
where someone would do this
and then from Brianna Wu she says this
Spike of hate crimes is very clearly on
Libs of tick tock Matt Walsh and the
anti-trans mainstream media that has
smeared LGBT people as sexual deviants
and from trans activist Alejandra
carabayo he tweeted quote these people
like Libs of tick tock Matt walls
trucker Carlson Christopher rufo have
spent all year stoking and inciting
violence against lgbtq people when the
violence happens they deny it minimize
it and double down on the hate they are
sick twisted sociopaths
another activist posted this is where
the hateful rhetoric that's allowed to
spit on this platform eventually leads
Shia right chick Matt Walsh Etc will
continue spewing bile trying to escalate
words into physical violence we keep us
safe
Etc and so forth many more where those
came from
the message is clear I must be silenced
along with Shia raichik and Christopher
rufo and other conservatives because our
rhetoric
is causing shootings to happen
but what is our rhetoric exactly
have any of us ever called for violence
no of course not I mean if we had then
they'd have the clips of those and those
would be circulating but they don't
because we never said that
are we running around attacking gay
people as a group simply for existing
no we're not doing that
again if we had done that then the clips
would be out there you could be sure of
it
we are in the left's crosshairs for two
very specific reasons two reasons
we oppose the medical transition of
minors
and we don't think that children should
be involved in drag shows
that's it
that's the hateful rhetoric they're
talking about all of the alleged
anti-lgbt laws that glad mentioned are
exclusively focused on those two issues
No Children of drag shows no children
getting gender Transitions and then we
can add a third one too is is that uh we
we should not be destroying female
sports by allowing males to plan it so
those all the laws
when it comes to LGBT people are about
that
which is another way of saying that the
laws don't focus on LGBT people at all
they don't put any restrictions on LGBT
people
unless the left is saying that exposing
kids to drag shows is like a an
elemental
inextricable part of Gay Culture if that
is that what they are that's apparently
what they are saying that's what they
are claiming
I mean what other conclusion could I
draw if I say kids shouldn't be at drag
shows and then you respond by saying
this is an attack on LGBT people
I didn't even say anything about LGBT
I don't care who's there I don't care
who's involved
I don't care if they're gay straight
whatever
kids don't belong at burlesque shows
so all of us
you know this is focused on protecting
children from castration mutilation and
sexualization
that's our dastardly agenda
which the left claims is somehow
spawning violence
in other words they are using a mass
shooting as a way to Blackmail us into
accepting the abuse of children
people die
and as soon as the bodies hit the ground
these demons think yes we can use this
as ammo against conservatives who don't
think children should be exposed to drag
shows
just imagine that
people are dead and that's the first
thing these demented freaks think
the first thing they think
seeing the bodies hit the ground the
first thing they think is oh oh this is
this is great yeah now we can now we can
silence people who are saying kids
shouldn't be at drag shows
why do they do this
I mean why do they play this game well
because they know that they can't defend
their positions otherwise they want the
kids at the drag shows they want them in
the sex change clinics but they dare not
defend either stance out loud they can't
so instead they resort to the worst kind
of emotional manipulation which is the
only tool that these scumbags have in
their toolbox is emotional manipulation
that's all they've got
in this case gleefully exploiting the
deaths of the very people they pretend
to care about but they don't care about
them
they don't care about anyone or anything
and except their demented ideological
agenda
there is no tactic they won't resort to
no depth to which they will not plunge
in pursuit of that agenda
and to silence those who oppose it
and I must tell them once again
is not going to work
not in my case it won't
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
if you're listening to this show odds
are that you put a lot of stock into how
you raise your kids you understand that
your children look to you to Define
their values and their perspectives of
the world that's why it's extremely
important that you have a will in place
a will also determines how your
financial assets are dispersed as well
as your personal property it lays out
your health care power of attorney to
ensure that your end-of-life decisions
are carried out if you're just starting
out and you don't have thousands of
dollars to spend on an attorney but you
want to make sure your savings your
belongings and your family are all
protected you have to create a will at
epicwill.com today epic Wheels early
estate plans started just 119 dollars
and you can save 10 percent when you use
promo code Walsh all you got to do if
you want to take advantage of this is go
to
epicwill.com use promo code Walsh to
save 10 percent on Epic Wills complete
will package you don't want to wait till
it's too late to make sure that your
family is taken care of so you want to
take advantage of Epic Will's complete
package that's epicwill.com promo code
Welsh
I have to say one other thing here also
um just I and I have to note this I I
just am not persuaded
by the hateful rhetoric hand ringing
especially as it comes from the same
people who make death threats against me
every day okay
I mean I I have in the past trended on
Twitter because there were so many
people doxing me and and threatening to
kill me and my family it happens in such
volume and so often that it results in
me trending because of it
and yet I'm supposed to take you
seriously when you pretend to care about
irresponsible rhetoric right after you
just threatened to kill me and my family
so if you're wondering if if you're
someone on the left you happen to be
watching this you're wondering well why
isn't he taking this more seriously
that's why
my children can't even walk down to
check the mailbox alone
because of the security threats
so that's what I'm dealing with okay
now I don't want you to think that that
means that we're huddling and cowering
in fear we're not
uh we're ready and if anyone ever came
looking to make good on any of these
threads it would be the biggest mistake
they ever make and the last mistake they
make
in their pitiful worthless lives
but
I I just
I am the I am not if you're looking for
someone to to to uh to take you
seriously on the hateful rhetoric stuff
I'm not the guy you're talking to the
wrong guy
I can't stomach the nonsense this uh
let's tone down the rhetoric
when you know someone threatening to
blow up my house is just another day at
the office
and and and why again I have to keep
emphasizing why
like what do they hate me so much for
what did I do to them
well I'm trying to stop them from
exposing themselves to children
and I'm trying to stop them from
castrating children that's it
they are so devoted to doing both of
those things
that they want you dead
and they want everyone You Love dead if
you try to stop them
sure tone down the rhetoric
okay
you know the World Cup kicked off this
weekend uh I think the World Cup is uh
that's the soccer thing and I don't
follow because I'm I'm more of a sports
fan personally but
and I don't have anything against soccer
I think soccer is a fine hobby you know
for children that is if you want your
children to become communists
um it's a great hobby for communist
children I suppose is what I'm saying I
don't mean any offense by that
um and it's not even the communism of
soccer that I have the biggest problem
with it's really it's it's it's mainly
that soccer makes baseball seem
thrilling by comparison which is very
hard to do
but anyway the World Cup did kick off
and we talked about last week There's
controversy over the fact that the World
Cup is in Qatar and Qatar is not exactly
known as like the gay rights capital of
the world okay it's not it's it's not
that precisely
um homosexuality is effectively illegal
there or literally illegal and uh this
is in conflict with FIFA that's the
World Cup's governing organization it's
in conflict with with all of the LGBT uh
virtue signaling that they usually do
they so they want to have their woke
cake and eat it too on one hand they
want to advertise themselves as Uber
woke on LGBT stuff but on the other hand
they want to take money from Qatar
this has led to criticism
and the U.S team addressed the criticism
by covering themselves in Rainbow Flags
head to toe uh they're going to try to
glitter and rainbow themselves out of
this gym
although it is kind of redundant you
know all the gay paraphernalia with
soccer
um
because we see that and everyone's like
you're a soccer team we know we get it
but the president of FIFA his name is
Gianni Infantino uh took it a step
further he gave a press conference
defending his decision to send the World
Cup to Qatar and it was uh it was
something I have to say so let's he
starts by by telling us how he feels
what he's feeling and it's well just
listen
ever very strong feelings I can tell you
that
today I feel
Qatari
today I feel Arab
today I feel African
today I feel gay
today I feel disabled
today I feel
a migrant worker
that is that is uh that's the funniest
thing I've seen in a long time that is
literally something out of the office I
mean that is that I think that's almost
verbatim a speech that Michael Scott
gave on diversity day at the office I
think and he's so proud of himself too
he's he thinks he's saying something
profound he has this look on his face
it's like it's the Kamala Harris look
right it's you know uh where he's he's
sputtering nonsense but but thinks that
he's nailing it and perhaps the greatest
lines ever delivered in the history of
public speaking today I feel gay today I
feel disabled
and you note though a short pause before
he said gay like he was having second
thoughts about going this direction but
he already committed to it so he just
went with it and then he felt pretty
good about it uh and then also notice
another thing too
that he said
I feel a migrant worker
he didn't say I feel like a migrant
worker inside that he said I feel a
migrant worker
so this is maybe a confession as well
in any case that's not really the part
that I want to focus on that's just uh
that's it's a little bit of uh of
comedic relief
um he then goes on into this rant to
justify FIFA's uh business with Qatar
this is what he says
we have told many many lessons
from
some Europeans
from the Western world
I'm European
actually I am European
not just I feel European
I think for what we Europeans have been
doing in the last 3000 years
around the world we should be
apologizing for next 3000 years
before starting to give moral lessons
to people
Europeans should apologize for the last
3 000 years that's how far back he's
indicting Europeans Europeans and
Americans too by extension for going
back 3 000 years right so
um and uh he's he's saying
that so it's really what he's really
said the Western World should apologize
for the past three thousand years so
we're going back to uh Aristotle and
before that well before that and
apologizing for what apologizing for
democracy for the concept of human
rights for modern science for modern
medicine for space travel for
electricity
for the fact that the human the human
life expectancy is over the age of 35
like is that what we're apologizing for
because you could thank the Western
World for all that and much more
basically
almost everything that makes your life
enjoyable and tolerable you can thank
the Western World for so if we're
apologizing for three thousand years
then we're apologizing for all that
now with that said
I would actually agree
that modern westerners
don't have much room to be lecturing
other cultures about anything
so that's the Nuance here if that's what
he was saying it's not what he said but
if you're saying modern westerners don't
then that part I would have to agree
because we we murder our babies here we
we as discussed we castrate our children
we sterilize them uh we are utterly
consumed right now tragically sadly
terribly by moral Madness
that's the modern West
which means that we're in no position to
lecture anyone morally on anything I
agree with that but but that's not what
he's talking about
he's bringing the indictment back
Millennia which means that he's saying
we should apologize for just our
existence for for all the good stuff
all the good stuff from the West the
stuff that uh that we are now abandoning
really
because the West if the West should
apologize for anything
today
the West should apologize for not being
Western enough that is I mean for
abandoning all that made the West great
especially when it comes to uh moral
insights the moral formation
what was once the wisdom of the West
we've abandoned that
and we are collapsing because of it and
so if we're gonna apologize for anything
yeah apologize for that
but He suggests we apologize for that
very foundation for the foundations of
the West if he wants to go back 3000
years
or else maybe he's talking about you
know slavery and Conquest
because that happened in the west
historically
and it that's true it did
but of course it happened everywhere
else in the world too and for longer
so when it comes to issues like slavery
racism that sort of thing
can you name a region of the world that
has a better record with that stuff than
the West does
the West is in no position to lecture
about that well who's who's in a better
position
what what part of the world when it
comes to if if he's speaking
specifically about
Conquest slavery racism
what region of the world has had a
better track record
outside of the western world
and it doesn't exist
it does it doesn't even come close to
existing
all right uh big social media news over
the weekend Trump was reinstated to
Twitter his account was brought back the
announcement was made by Elon Musk after
he conducted a poll asking people
whether Trump should be brought back and
there was uh I don't know there's tens
of millions of people voting in this
thing the yeas beat the Nays and his
account was restored just like that
now we don't have to review the
left-wing media freakout they obviously
freaked out and were very upset about it
and this was a day after a huge portion
of the remaining staff at Twitter was
cut and it wasn't that Elon fired him I
mean he did he gave what he gave him
Severance it was layoffs I suppose
but he he sent out an email to all
remaining staff members and said
uh look we got to turn this ship around
and it's going to mean long it's going
to mean long shifts and working hard for
the foreseeable future do you want to
work hard you want to put in the work or
not and if you don't
we'll give you three month Severance and
you can go and if you do let's get down
to business and a whole bunch of people
at Twitter said we don't want to we work
at Twitter you think we came here
because we want to work
you think we came to this place
with the Foosball table in the
meditation room and the wine on tap
now you don't go work at a place that
has wine on tap because you like to work
or you want to work or you're willing to
work
now for a lot of people Twitter is the
whole reason they're there so they don't
have to do anything and then Elon Musk
comes along and has the audacity to
suggest that if you're pulling in a
paycheck you should have to actually do
something in return for it
um
and so a bunch of them left there was a
mass Exodus and then we were told there
was a lot of leftist media people that
were as always very melodramatic about
it they were convinced that uh this
would be the end of Twitter Twitter
wouldn't be able to keep the lights on
and apparently on Friday night and I
wasn't on Twitter on Friday night
but
I try not to spend Friday nights on
Twitter that's that's how you know you
had a bad Friday night you know that's
how you know things are going wrong in
your life and you're spending Friday
night on Twitter but on Friday night
there were all these uh left especially
leftist media people melodramatically
posting their goodbyes to Twitter and
you know everything else because I
thought that they would wake up tomorrow
there'd be no Twitter because everything
would be gone but then Saturday morning
came and Twitter was still around for
better or worse
and then Trump came back
and they're obviously very upset about
that proving among other things
the fact that and I know this is not a
revelation but the left left-wing media
really does live in a Twitter bubble
and it's one of the things that's
destroying them now you want to if you
want to know why the ratings are
crashing for you know CNN a lot of these
uh uh Legacy cable news outlets and
everything
big part of the reason is that they're
in this Twitter bubble they don't know
yeah there's the there's the left-wing
bias but they've all the media's always
had that
the problem now is that they just have
no idea what people care about or what
news people actually care to hear or
need to hear
because they're in this bubble
uh and that was just perfectly
demonstrated by how they've been
carrying on over the last few days
like if you walked up to any random
person on the street anywhere
and you ask them if they're aware of any
of this drama involving Twitter
they'll almost certainly say no they're
going to look at you confused
in fact Twitter could disappear and the
average person on the street wouldn't
even know about it
and if they found out they'd say
something like oh good and they would
just carry on with their lives
because most people aren't on Twitter
they don't care about it they don't know
what's happening there
and that's all there is to it I mean
it's okay to use Twitter obviously I do
but if you're in the if you're in the
news media you have to keep the bubble
phenomenon in mind or you'll become
hopelessly out of touch as they have
um
now for his part Trump so Trump's
account is back
but then the next question is whether
Trump will actually come back and post
on Twitter and uh he was speaking at the
Republican Jewish Coalition on Saturday
and was asked about this and uh here's
his answer
Mr President I want to Pivot a little
bit to current events as in happening in
real time I don't know if you've been
following uh Twitter is blowing up today
Elon Musk posted a poll that had over 13
million responded so far asking whether
or not you should be reinstated uh on on
Twitter my question to you is what do
you think about Elon Musk buying Twitter
and if you are reinstated will we see
you back on Twitter again
well I like that he bought it I've
always liked him I got along with him
very well during my days as president
and I got to know him pretty well but I
do like him I've I've always really you
know he's a he's a character
and I tend to like characters but he's
smart
he did put up a poll and I hear it's
very overwhelming very strong but I have
something called Trump
if you look at strombone but it's uh
it's really fantastic truth social and
Truth social uh is is through the roof
it's doing phenomenally well the press
hates to talk about it but it's doing
phenomenally well I think engagement is
much better than it is with Twitter
and it's taking care of voices that
really want to be taken care of and
really smart voices brilliant voices
voices that in many cases are both sides
but I can tell you there's a lot of
voice for Israel a lot of power for
Israel
in true social so true social has been
very very powerful very very strong and
I'll be staying there but I hear we're
getting a big vote to also go back on
Twitter uh I I don't see it because I
don't see any reason for it they have a
lot of problems at Twitter you see
what's going on it may naked it may not
make it but the problems are incredible
the engagements are
negative and you have a lot of bots and
you have a lot of fake accounts which I
think they should get on but truth
social has taken the place for a lot of
people and I don't see them going back
onto Twitter
I don't think it's true that uh truth
social has more engagement than Twitter
um but
pretty sure that's not the case so this
is interesting interesting question
actually it's two questions
um Will trump
come back to Twitter maybe three
questions I keep adding Will trump come
back to Twitter
should he come back to Twitter and does
it matter at all I just talked about the
Twitter bubble and here I am talking
about well will here won't he you know
that's what people on Twitter are
talking about it's the big question
um does it actually matter like for the
average uh Trump voter potential Trump
voter are they you know are they
benefited one way or another by Trump
being on on uh on Twitter
and I guess for all those questions for
the question of whether he'll come back
I I I I don't know I I tend to think he
probably will I mean he's got he is he
has more followers on Twitter than there
are you know total users of Truth social
probably by a rather large margin I
would think and so he's got access even
though Twitter again still is in a
bubble it's it's it's a much bigger
bubble you know if if Twitter is a
bubble it's a pretty big one whereas
truth social is a much smaller bubble
and uh especially if you're running for
president again it makes sense to get
into the bigger bubble I don't know if
he will
but if he does then that would be the
reasoning
then the question is is should he
actually do that like would it would it
benefit him to be on Twitter
um
and I'm I'm in the minority here I
realize I think I'm in the minority
among people on the right
and when I when I say I don't think he
should I think it's better if he's not
um
I I think in general and I feel this way
it's not just about Trump about
politicians in general
I don't know if politicians or
candidates
are helped
by giving us direct access to their
stream of consciousness
I'm not sure that that helps
ultimately
and you know you can say well Trump is
different he's different kind of
politician and he certainly is so if
that if any politician could be helped
by that then he would be the one but
even then I think that this is probably
a general rule and yeah 2016 he won in
2016 you could say that that uh you know
that that was proofs in the pudding
there but I don't think he won in 2016
because he was on because he was
tweeting right
I mean he won by mobilizing blue-collar
voters in in some of these crucial
States and I don't think that these it's
because he was on Twitter
um
I think it's just his overall kind of
presence
now the benefit of Twitter is that he's
able to get his own thoughts out there
without going through the media like he
doesn't have to issue a statement
through the media you can just put it
out there for people to see that is a
benefit but he actually can accomplish
that on on Truth social
he already uses that as kind of a forum
for issuing statements and then the
media picks those up and they end up on
Twitter anyway so that's the interesting
thing the funny thing is that he's
effectively on Twitter whether he wants
to be or not because by posting a true
social whatever he post there ends up
all over Twitter anyway
um
but I guess it's really a question of is
it better for him to go back on Twitter
and go back to what it was years ago
when he was just tweeting all the time
and uh is that going to help in the
campaign and I I I tend to think not I I
think it's better as a politician to be
more
selective in the ideas and thoughts that
you decide to put out into the world
all right
CNN has this President Joe Biden turns
80 years old on Sunday turned 80 year
old 80 years old on Sunday becoming the
first octogenarian to ever serve in the
highest Office of the United States the
unique Milestone of Biden's birthday
comes as the president faces speculation
about whether he will mount a
re-election run and dredges up questions
about whether he's too old to serve
another term and then this CNN article
goes actually into detail about all
these questions and the questions about
um Biden's mental acuity and so on
because we're past the midterms now and
I think we're going to see more and more
of this we're going to see more and more
of the media
criticizing Biden raising these kinds of
issues
that of course you weren't allowed to
talk about as a conspiracy theory to
talk about them during the campaign but
now you can talk about them because they
don't they obviously don't want Biden to
run for re-election they want to get
some other Democrat in there who who
Who's got a better shot than by you know
Biden is a terrible
candidate and has been the worst
arguably the worst president in history
but who else do you have you know
there's there's no one on the bench
ready to come in ready to jump in and
play
but still they want they figure I think
they figure anyone is better than Biden
at this point they might be right about
that
so we're actually going to see a lot
more of this we're going to see the the
media uncharacteristically
criticizing a Democrat Administration
seeming to sort of hold them accountable
but it's only they wouldn't be doing
that if they didn't think that they
could benefit from it politically it's
because they see a political benefit
of chasing this guy out
sending a message to him now don't run
again so they can get somebody else in
there it's the only reason
and of course
as far as someone turning 80 in office
that is just
in absurdity as I've been saying for
years
if we were a serious country there would
be laws on the books
there's a minimum age requirement to be
president so it only stands a reason
there should be a maximum age as well
I think 75 makes a lot of sense 35 to 75
you got 40 years to do it
um
40 years to run
right I mean if you turn 75 while you're
at office that's one thing but you got
you have 40 years to decide to run and
win and if you don't then
you know you still had you had a good
four decades
all right I want to mention this before
we get to the comment section it's no
secret you know that we live in a
country filled with emotionally fragile
people
um and that's why we have innovated a
wide array of emotional crutches and
emotional supports
you can turn to a therapist or a
counselor psychiatrist a psychologist a
bottle of prescription pills
an emotional support animal
a therapeutic uh professional cuddler is
a thing now too
and then there's also this New York the
New York Post reports on one of the
latest examples
it says can't bear to be alone this
holiday season a human-sized emotional
support bear might be the perfect gift
for you the loving bear puffy is the
shape and size of a male human body but
has the head of a teddy bear
just look at that thing there it is
puffy is a very personal product
invented by an ordinary woman who is
afraid of being alone the company said
uh the five foot seven inch oversized
plush bear weighing just seven pounds is
160 and replaces the need for the
physical presence of a person in various
moments and situations of everyday life
especially during long long nights so
this this lonely woman apparently she
couldn't make do with cats and so she
invented this and it's put on sale for
160 this is indeed a wonderful gift for
the serial killer in your life if you
want to help the creepy bastard in your
life become even creepier then this is a
good gift for them
I mean I don't know you well I mentioned
those those professional cuddling
Services people hire actual humans to
cuddle them
and that seems even worse than this so
maybe maybe this this could be a good
way to wean somebody off of that
if they're addicted to the professional
cuddling services or maybe it's the
other way around what's worse the higher
professional cuddler
or to buy a six foot tall human eye
humanoid teddy bear to cuddle with
which would make you more ashamed if you
were the parent of an adult child
engaging in this activity it's
impossible to say
what I will say on a slightly more
serious note is that there is
a loneliness epidemic in this country
people are very lonely they're alone
they're they're desperate for some kind
of human contact
even if they have to pay for it or
settle for a giant teddy bear instead
we have tried to make people in this
culture into these kind of autonomous
entities telling them that they they
don't need marriage they don't need
families they don't need anyone as long
as you have the cold bureaucratic
Embrace of the state then you'll be fine
but it turns out that doesn't work
it doesn't satiate the longing of the
human heart
and that's what leads to this
then again I have no room to talk I am
the guy with the life-size stuffed
walrus so no that isn't for cuddling
that's strictly for decor
unless I have a really bad day which
case all bets are off
let's get to the comment sections
[Music]
you know I love finding easy ways to
support a healthy routine which is why
I'm so excited about tart cherry gummies
from the makers of superbeets heart
chews tart cherry gummies are an easy
way to support your metabolic health and
reduce inflammation from exercise made
with a clinically studied tart cherry
extract that is up to 40 times more
concentrated than many other tart cherry
extracts just two tart cherry gummies
are the antioxidant equivalent of 16
ounces of tart cherry juice or 100
cherries formulated by a team of
scientists led by Nobel prize-winning
doctors tart cherry has been clinically
studied to support metabolic health I
had tart cherry gummies for the first
time the other day after finishing up a
workout and I could really tell the
difference I can tell you that they're
also delicious so right now you can get
up to 35 off tart cherry gummies plus
free shipping at mytartsherry.com Walsh
this is their best offer available
anywhere that's my tart cherry.com Walsh
for up to 35 off tart cherry gummies
that's my tart cherry.com Walsh these
statements and products have not been
evaluated by the the FDA these products
are not intended to diagnose treat cure
or prevent any disease or condition
CC says the siren in the background as
Matt talks about San Francisco's issues
is too good yeah I noticed that
yesterday on the show on Thursday we
were in San Francisco before the
Berkeley event and I was complaining
about San Francisco because it's just a
hard
filthy dirty place as I was complaining
about it you could hear all these cop
cars in the background I just you
couldn't have we couldn't have scripted
it any better
um 6 23 says completely agreed with
Matt's driving style use any all lanes
available zipper merge don't take
anything personally and be courteous on
the road using the full available Lanes
is much more efficient for congestion
Than People merging three miles before
emerges thank you that's exactly right
and I think that's one of the most
important tips in driving aside from use
the space available to you of course
that too but but don't take things
personally people taking things too
personally on the road that's how you
end up with uh you know road rage
incidents of people getting shot dead
and all the rest of it
um
let's see Noah says Matt I think it's
important when discussing the culture
War issues I would find it very helpful
if you would please make the distinction
between whether your position is that
something should be made into law or
whether you are trying to persuade your
fellow citizens on what they should do
this is something that stuck out to me
with you and Joe Rogan discussing gay
marriage and you were both kind of
missing each other because of that I
think SBG for life
yeah I do think it's important to
sanction to make I did make that
distinction
um it's just that for some reason
you could try to make these distinctions
this is this is a problem we have as
conservatives and maybe we don't make
the distinctions clearly enough
sometimes but I have found that even
when you make them it's like the other
side just doesn't hear it
and so
we were talking about kind of two things
one was the issue of marriage where I do
think the law has a place I'm not one of
these get government out of marriage
people
and then it got into also well uh what
you know kind of
the the the procreative nature of
marriage and should uh you know what
about heterosexual couples that get
married and then choose not to have kids
I said well they should make they they
sh if you get married
and you're able to have kids then you
should I do think that you're called to
to do that that's part of what marriage
is about and you're declining to
participate in one of the most crucial
aspects of marriage
and that sent us down this road of well
there can't be laws
uh forcing people to have kids well of
course I can't so I'm not when I say
should I'm not saying that there should
be a law forcing it I'm just saying that
I think that that's what people should
ought to do
so I think the distinction was made but
it's not always uh heard I guess Jack
says hi Matt I know how you feel about
Trump versus DeSantis but if Trump wins
the primary would you still support him
in the general
uh support Trump in the general yeah of
course I would as opposed to what Biden
some other Democrat that's obviously I
would support him in the general it's
not even there's nothing to think about
there my whole objection is that I think
DeSantis is the more effective
Republican candidate this is this is my
probably my primary objection I think
he's the president he's the more
effective Republican candidate in the
general
but if he's not the Republican candidate
in the general then then he's not and so
that's it um and then Trump if Trump's
the guy then I would support him
obviously I would
um I I do also think that DeSantis would
would make a better president in the
year 2024
but that point is somewhat irrelevant
you know this this isn't about who would
make a better president because they
aren't facing each other in a general
election
if they face each other it's going to be
in a primary so the real question is who
would be a better candidate who has a
better chance of winning
right now the only thing that matters is
winning
who has the best chance to win who is
able to beat the Democrats that's all
that matters for right now our political
philosophy as we head into 2024 should
be winning that's it who can win
um and come primary season we should all
make our decision whatever it is based
entirely on who has the best chance of
winning the general period right now I
think that's DeSantis I don't
I don't see that Trump has a better path
in 2024 than DeSantis does if you see it
then let me know what it is because I
right now I don't see it
and as I've said one of the one of the
biggest problems that Trump is going to
face
is that for him so much is already baked
in
like there's how many persuadable voters
are there when it comes to Donald Trump
who who who is out there right now who
doesn't already have an opinion about
Donald Trump
he's the most famous guy in the world
like everyone has an opinion about him
and so who can you win over who isn't
already won over
um with DeSantis
the the ceiling is not set because most
people and we know the left people that
are on the far left hate his guts a lot
of people on the right who like him but
then there's a lot of people that are
not on the far right or far left who
don't really know much about them and so
are potentially persuadable
that's to me one of the biggest issues
here
already so many of you have visited the
brand new DW Plus store and picked up my
new sweet baby album t-shirt it's the
perfect gift to yourself and everyone
you know because there's just something
in the way they put my bearded infant
self on a t-shirt that no one can resist
you weirdos but there are so many other
items that you can pick up this holiday
season we have bundles where you can
pick up my best-selling lgbtq plus
children's book Johnny walrus and the
cuddly companion walrus plushie that you
need as well or pick up the Matt wall
superfan bundle a collection of some of
the best items we have that have
launched this year it's the perfect gift
for any and all sweet babies this
holiday season so head over to my
collection over dailywire.com shop and
get the sweet baby album t-shirt or any
of the other amazing holiday offerings
at the new and improved daily wire plus
shop free shipping on orders over 75
dollars any free leftist tears tumbler
with all orders over a hundred dollars
get your daily wire gifts today because
um some items are already close to
selling out again go to dailywire.com
shop and get yours before they are gone
also you know Jeremy's razors may have
started as the best joke we ever told
but now it's more real than ever if you
don't know the backstory last year
Harry's dropped their ads from our
Network condemning our views as
inexcusable because someone around here
dared to say that boys are girl boys or
boys and girls or girls rather but
rather than boycott Harry's uh you know
back daily wire co-ceo and God King
Jeremy boring started his own rival
razor company and his quest to earn your
business from those wool companies that
hate you the god King has turned a
single yet glorious razor into a
triumphant new line of men's products
products like a nourishing shampoo and
conditioner charcoal body wash luxurious
beard kit and a new Precision 5 razor
with flip back trimmer yes they're all
very real and they're very spectacular
in fact Jeremy's razors couldn't get any
more real because unlike those other
woke razor companies Jeremy's is the
only company built on Truth like the
truth that masculinity is not toxic and
that men cannot be women so if you're
ready to get a great shave or
exfoliating wash from a company that
refuses to pay to play pretend or to bow
down to the woke mob go to
jeremy'srazors.com today and remember
stop giving your money to woke companies
that hate you give it to Jeremy instead
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
well it's a short week so we don't have
time to mess around we're gonna have to
jump right in on a Monday with one of
the most richly deserving cancellations
we've ever done on this show this is not
a regular cancellation but another of
our patented reverse cancellations where
the cancellers who are attempting to
cancel someone else instead that they
find that they themselves are canceled
by me
though they may not notice because as of
yet my daily cancellations carry no
enforcement mechanism which is the Fatal
flaw that's something that will surely
change once I'm finally installed as
Theocratic fascist dictator of the
country but for now it begins with um
the highly lauded four-star High School
quarterback Marcus Stokes who had
recently been extended a scholarship
offer from the University of Florida
Stokes was set to head down to Florida
this summer to begin his college
football career but then things went
sideways according to the media reports
video surfaced of Stokes using a racial
slur that's the way it's being phrased
on a lot of the headlines he's using or
saying a racial slur it took about 48
hours to the university University of
Florida to respond the way that
spineless Solace bureaucrat
bureaucracies always respond in these
kinds of situations and they threw the
kid under the bus and withdrew the
scholarship offer almost immediately and
it's likely that this will have a
cascading effect and all the other
schools that had shown interest in
Stokes will also back away his life
could be profoundly altered because of
this moment and not for the better
but what about that terrible video with
the terrible awful racial slurp
well it turns out that Stokes was not
caught on tape screaming the n-word at a
black person or engaging in any other
sort of racist rant that's not what
happened
he was in fact simply singing along to a
rap song that's all
Stokes tried to explain this in a
statement that he issued after the
decision in Florida was made public he
posted quote I was in my car listening
to rap music rapping along to the words
and posted a video of it on social media
I deeply apologize for the words and
that's in in the song that I chose to
say it was hurtful and offensive to many
people and I regret that I fully accept
the consequences of my actions and I
respect the University of Florida's
decision to withdraw my scholarship
offer to play football my intention was
never to hurt anybody and I recognize
that even when going along with a song
My Words still carry a lot of weight I
will strive to be better and to become
the best version of myself both on and
off the field
I know that learning from my mistakes is
a first important step
now
you know what I say about apologizing to
the cancel mob never do it
especially when you've done nothing
wrong
but I'm not going to blame Stokes here
he's just a high school kid Suddenly at
the center of a totally fake and
engineered public outrage
in fact speaking of being fake and
engineered it's not a coincidence that
Florida had in the last few weeks
managed to pull another high value
recruit who had previously committed to
the University of Miami so he had they
had flipped that recruit and the
recruiter committed to them
so it seems likely to me that Florida
created this controversy themselves so
they'd have an excuse to dump Stokes and
get rid of the uh of the of the the
scholarship they offered them in favor
of the other recruit who they like more
and if that means that uh destroying his
college career in the process is the way
to go then what do they care
one thing that's always been clear about
NCAA football programs is that the
people running them don't give a damn
about the kids playing for them that's
for sure
the point is that again
the controversy and outrage was as
always 100 fake and contrived
Stokes apologized to those he had hurt
and offended but that is a group that
consists of precisely zero people not
one person on Earth was hurt because a
high school kid sang along to a rap song
and and if such a fragile emotionally
unstable person does exist somewhere on
this godforsaken planet their feelings
don't matter
in fact it is a positive good that such
a person should have their feelings hurt
if they had their feelings hurt I'm glad
they did
anyone actually offended by a video of a
kid named Marcus Stokes singing a rap
song
deserves to experience whatever
emotional trauma they're currently going
through
I'm glad it hurts I hope it hurts more
that's what I wish Stokes had said
but I certainly don't blame him for not
saying that the kid was just one you
know he just wants to play football he
didn't sign up to take on the faux
outrage mob at least he didn't think
that he signed up for that
now to State the obvious here
Marcus Stokes
is not the first college football
recruit to ever say the n-word okay that
so breaking news
not the first college football recruit
to say in fact it is certain that
Florida's locker room is currently full
of players who say the n-word all the
time they say it in the locker room they
say it on the field they say it on the
sidelines they say it on camera they say
it in social media videos
yet Marcus Stokes said it once while
singing along to a song and he was cast
out as a racist because of it
how can this contradiction be justified
Well it can't be justified of course
the only difference between Stokes and
all the hundreds of thousands of college
football players who hundreds or
thousands of college football players
who use the word freely
dozens of times a day is that Stokes has
lighter skin pigmentation
right it's the skin pigment that's
that's the only difference
the rule as it has been established is
that if your skin is a darker shade of
brown
you can say the word whenever you want
to whoever you want in whatever context
you want if your skin is a lighter shade
of brown you cannot say it in any
context whatsoever no matter the
circumstances because when it passes
from your pale lips the word itself
suddenly magically changes in meaning
and becomes an unutterable curse an
unspeakable slur the worst sort of
vulgar vulgarity ever known to man
that's the rule
though the rule makes no sense on any
logical or moral level whatsoever
which is why none of the Defenders of
this rule have ever been able to
actually defend it
so let me show you what I mean
in the wake of the Marcus Stokes pseudo
Scandal there was another video that's
uh getting passed around on social media
this is a video from a few years ago
where the author tanahisi Coates
explains tries to explain why only black
people can say the n-word and I'm told
by The Advocates of this rule that this
is a thorough thoughtful explanation and
defense of the rule and indeed it is
probably as thorough and thoughtful an
explanation and defense as anyone could
possibly offer but that should tell you
something once you hear how weak and
self-contradictory it actually is
listen
words don't have meaning without context
okay
um my wife refers to me as honey
that's accepted and okay between us if
we were walking down the street together
and a strange woman referred to me as
Han
that wouldn't be acceptable
the understanding is I have some sort of
relationship with my wife hopefully I
have no relationship with this strange
woman
when I was young and I used to go see my
family uh in in Philadelphia where my
dad was from they will all call him
Billy his name is William Paul Coates
um no one in Baltimore called him Billy
and had I referred to my father as Billy
that probably would have been a problem
that's because the relationship between
myself and my dad is not the same as the
relationship between my dad and his
mother and his sisters who he grew up
with right we understand that
um
it's the same thing with words within
the African-American Community or within
any Community my wife with her
girlfriend who used the word [ __ ]
I do not join in I don't you know Say
Hey I want to
I don't do that
I don't do that
and perhaps more importantly I don't
have a desire to do it you understand
you know um a while ago Dan Savage was
gonna have this uh show that he was
going to call hey [ __ ] I'm not gonna
yell [ __ ] a dance I'm just not that's
not my relationship with the LGBT
community and I understand that and I'm
okay with that I don't have a desire to
you know uh yell out the word you know
in fact I just don't have that
um the question one must ask if that's
accepted
and normal for groups of people we
understand that you know it's normal
actually for groups to use words that
are derogatory in an ironic fashion why
is there so much hand-wringing when
black people do it
um
black people are basically you know
however you feel about it they're not
outside of the normal rules and laws for
Humanity I had a you know a good friend
who used to have this um
cabin in Upstate New York which he
referred to as the white trash cap he
was white I would never refer to that
cabinet I would never tell him I'm
coming to your white trash cabin
I just wouldn't do that I and you know
what I mean I think you understand why I
wouldn't do it the question one must ask
is why so many white people have
difficulty extending things that are
basic
laws
you know of how human beings interact to
black people
okay where to even begin here I guess we
just begin at the beginning he says that
context matters I agree with that indeed
when judging someone's words context is
all that matters you cannot begin to
understand what someone is saying or why
or whether their words are objectionable
or not until you take into account the
context I agree with that the problem is
that coats does not agree with it
he gives the example of his wife using
the pet name honey for him he says that
his wife can call him honey but if
anyone else called him honey it might be
an issue but he's already abandoned the
statement that he made at the start
context matters
sure if some other young woman called
him honey in a flirtatious way that
would be unacceptable but what if it was
some sweet old woman at the grocery
store called him honey we could probably
assume that his wife wouldn't respond by
smacking her across the face
honey is a perfect example of a word
that changes dramatically depending on
who is saying it and why and why they're
saying it that's the context why are you
saying it
and what if his wife wrote him a a love
letter A poem and in the poem called him
honey then she published the poem in a
book and put it on sale at Barnes and
Noble and then what if someone else
bought the book and read the poem out
loud that she published would it be
inappropriate for them to read the word
honey should they call it the H word
it's so important to his wife that
nobody else ever say the word honey in
relation to him if that's so important
why would she publish it in a book in a
forum that is made to be read out loud
you see the difference here
in fact and yes his wife calls him honey
in a particular context
if anyone else called him honey in that
same context it'd be a problem
and yet the whole rest of the world can
run around calling saying the word honey
for any number of other reasons they
could even say it to him
and as long as it is not specifically
being used to flirt with him his wife's
not going to have an issue with it
so coats inadvertently disproves his own
Point especially when he mentions the F
slur for gay people
okay he says that uh he would never use
that word in relation to gays
he would never use the word [ __ ] in
relation to gays
fine except that you notice he says the
word while talking about it true he
wouldn't call a gay person that word
fine but he will at least say the word
the actual whole word out loud while
talking about the word
in fact he uses all of the words he says
them all out loud while claiming that he
would never use them that's because
every other word in the English language
every single one without exception
except for the one exception
can be used by everyone of all Races and
ethnicities in certain contexts
you take any word that can be considered
a slur towards certain groups and uh and
and members of outside that group can
use it at least when talking about the
word or when reading something that has
a word or when quoting someone
the n-word is the only word in existence
the only one
that cannot be said in any context at
all even as a quote even as lyrics in a
song If your skin pigment is too light
so code says that context matters but
his actual view is that when it comes to
the n-word context doesn't matter that's
way that's the argument he's actually
making is that there is no context at
all when a white person can so much as
utter the syllables
so he says that he wants black people to
enjoy the same right to their own words
that all other groups enjoy that's not
true he wants black people to enjoy a
privilege that no other group on the
planet has ever had
that is the privilege to say certain
words in whatever context they want
while not allowing people in other
groups to say it in any context
there is no other example of a word like
that I dare you to prove me wrong find
one other word that that you could be
have your life destroyed for saying in
any context even if you're just reading
something if you're quoting someone
if you're singing a song
now clearly he can't actually justify or
defend any of this
nobody can I mean the idea that just
like the syllables themselves if you put
them together audibly
and you and you don't have dark enough
skin it's automatically offensive no
matter what that just doesn't make any
sense it's like it's like superstitious
you're turning a word into it into a
magical incantation like some sort of
curse that you found in a old dusty book
in the Attic it doesn't make any sense
it is morally and logically incoherent
cannot be defended
which is why he doesn't defend it
that's the theme on this show the people
on the left they cannot defend anything
they think
and that's why he is canceled along with
the University of Florida and everyone
else who thinks that a young man should
be punished for singing the lyrics to A
mass-produced and distributed pop song
they're all canceled
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you tomorrow Godspeed
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]